hey I was going bros - it is my honor
today and privilege to be playing until
dawn for you breasts let's keep playing
I'm so sorry about the cliffhanger in
the last one all right I really just had
to go these things happen
please forgive me okay we're Pat you're
not angry cool
well I'm I'm glad we can move passing so
if you missed it we're down here there
supposed to be a ghost all right we saw
some creepy things and supernatural
things seems to be an element in this
game which I was kind of hoping it would
not be and if it is is introduced too
late it should have been introduced to
first so you would think that gonna kill
or a super neck is that spook air to me
all right I would have loved to game
they love jump scares they were [ __ ] I
love I love catalogues of the is that a
clue
look color perhaps let's take the
scissor that is a creepy ass kisser oh
okay all right a lot of people died
I think Peter Stormare is gonna be
pissed at us again so let's make sure we
do this right Oh disgusting gross oh
look there's your bris time to get the
[ __ ] out that's what it was manis and
we'll be fine
look at this we're fine this is so
creepy if I was in a situation like this
[Music]
yes this maybe explains the spirits I
was just trying to find a weapon and
always be on guard for someone else you
know I don't think I can take any more
of this yeah my limit here - all I
wanted to do was forget last year ever
happened and to be honest I'm not sure
we Hannah thought she was doing yeah
well you know how it is when you're
crushing pretty hard on somebody great
Sears basically saying that we put a
vulnerable friend in a terrible
situation and essentially caused her to
run away and never to be heard from
again
if it was you don't you think you would
have run away
I mean who likes being made fun of in
front of all your friends - in front of
me - your face hahaha
Chris we made her look so stupid
in front of all of her friends yeah guys
she liked yeah I can't imagine doing
anything worse to somebody I mean I can
imagine some things but I I do agree
with her as a cannon it was anyone a
funny prank like that's suspicious but I
think that's my problem with it but
would I smell with that but would hang
called both would have smoke man all
right cat lady oh that's her bracelet
Sam's bracelet and she never takes this
thing off did the bracelet take off
itself fast we're getting philosophy
call as your sentence don't worry about
it let's go in here what do we get
creepy creepy boo a clue perhaps ex
janitor there is disco loose everywhere
fake are these fake why would anyone
make fake newspapers that's well then
the other question is obviously
so that was it that was a fake
that was a fake information that the ex
janitor swears revenge that wasn't true
interesting it's obvious that the
janitor is nice right he hasn't killed
anyone it's the clown guy that's killed
people
then what's your [ __ ] idea okay I'm
really freaked out too but if Sam's down
there all alone with a maniac
and we leave we're basically killing her
ourselves I want to find Sam god damn it
Ashley come on why are you always right
it's not always right well when you're
right you're right I want to leave no
we've got to find Sam let's go give her
a kiss of encouragement and a slap on
the back Oh dad
I like her eggs
they're very chic but her to rest of her
outfit you know look at that hat it does
not even match okay what do we got down
here I love those close-ups Chris I'm
getting a really weird feeling from all
this what do you mean well I just I
can't shake the feeling that those fake
newspapers have something to do with the
guy who killed Josh wait without like
like what like it's a setup or something
yeah but I mean how it's just it almost
makes sense but I just feels like we're
missing something
what are we missing I guess
I'll ship them so much sorry got fangirl
problem maybe we should just look for
ooh that's not good that's very bad
timed batteries TV and lights so that
means they can turn them on on a timer
interesting okay that's cool
wonder what that's about that could
explain maybe some supernatural elements
then again we saw a [ __ ] witch jump
up in our face alright and it was not
cool it was not cool at all
great there's mannequins that's it's
just what we needed wasn't it creepy as
mannequins huh
my god what do we got here oh come on I
wonder where we're gonna cut off with a
scissor I don't like this the guy didn't
even say anything this is our [ __ ] data
mine that's all
god damn it I can't believe Maddy bees
dead I did B is not even here
Maddy B [ __ ] me man josh is not crossed
over
so it's not about who's that it was that
guy oh sorry I didn't see him Christ
guess the ghost killed Matty be careful
he met if he died and it infuriates me
he was he did not like deserve to die
okay I just wanted to check that first
well let's go and find some clues here
cuz this is where he went right hate
going without knowing where you're gonna
come through ash I can't hold over there
yes are you sure I don't know but come
on I think we should check it out yeah
well pretty sure whoever's bleeding came
through here okay so we've really gotta
get moving like down oh my god
this is great this is great all right
I'm glad that happened I know it
probably wasn't the best move but it's
the move I wanted I can't wait
by the end of this to see how my life
choices were made the butterfly effect
thing it's a really cool premise of a
game I mean it's done before but this
this one has taken it in a way that
feels farther than anyone do you boys
remember beyond and why were you holding
that thing dude I have no frickin idea
why did you bring it with you you really
think it's you know I wanted to scare
you
we wanted to put a jump scare in the
game another one ice but yeah mostly for
Sam where where do you go I don't know
but we've got to be quiet
he's gotta be still really close awesome
oh [ __ ] she's still alive we gotta be
quiet
Sam Sam are you there [ __ ] idiots
oh my god wasn't she yelling a second
ago I was looking at it I knew it take a
scissor [ __ ] what living nurse the
[ __ ] was that about
oh god oh god oh god oh this is bad is
real [ __ ] bad I could tell you we're
always talking around it and now we
wasted every was wasted what do you mean
every second that I spent with you was
the only thing I ever wanted to do with
my time sure told you how I felt
[Music]
oh it's hard time you must make another
Chris you can take that gun in front of
you again shoot Ashley or you can shoot
your so the choice is yours
[Music]
give me shoot the locks
oh god this is too hard I hate this okay
all right think who do I dislike the
most I would kitten a lot I'd rather see
the guy live okay just proper [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
now what gives you the right to play God
these people's lives what make you
special then huh I can't really I shot
her I'm sorry
IRA I like him more you're a sick [ __ ]
psychopath come down Peter
psychopaths oh man I think if that was
real life I probably would have shot
myself cuz it's like how would you even
recover from an event like this
psychologically big you're better off
then but for the sake of the game I like
him more so the choice is yours oh [ __ ]
I just realized what if I didn't shoot
anyone oh god I'm such an idiot I should
have not shootin anyone
god dammit alright it's okay that's the
point of the game what was that thing I
can't believe Matty be dying I'm still
I'm still shocked over that MattyB night
[Music]
it's interesting to play games like this
when you actually like someone care of
the characters at least they have some
likeable traits like today's know
alright we're both captured
okay I bet you brothers are pissed at me
now for making that decision I'm so
sorry okay good job all right okay your
fingers my fingers Mike yeah he's trying
to kill us all
listen this guy who were talking about
he attacked me
he showed me these videos too and one of
them showed Josh being killed just
ripped apart by this huge [ __ ] saw
blade Jesus Christ what the [ __ ] is
going on around here there's a door here
it won't open
can you unlock it from your side that's
right
we still aren't wearing any [ __ ]
clothes this is bad this is really bad
press this game is emotionally hard to
play I feel like a weight on my
shoulders oh just so many emotions let's
see if I can open this now format man
it's like I can't wait to just play it
all over again already let's just see
how this plays out I guess see how the
ends what are you doing
well actually the tower didn't turn out
to be the best outfit for fighting off
killer maniacs you know do you mind
Mike oh right why didn't he just give
the jacket
do I get a choice to peek no yoga pants
they're back yay yay for yoga pants
what no are they still alive
Oh Chris
Oh Chris Chris Chris Chris [ __ ] you've
heard of blanks before I mean really
well shot huh
I know it I told I said I call I said
from [ __ ] mouths away Jess I'm so
smart get on my level game zero pivots
million right she lied ah come on
she got dead how is she not dead oh this
is getting interesting
oh [ __ ] I knew it I call that [ __ ] I
call that [ __ ] I [ __ ] called that
[ __ ] yes
I just want her to die like she's
wasting my [ __ ] time right now almost
missed it that was really [ __ ] pause
alright well it's just playing Uncharted
now did it this is so awesome
I'm so into this prize
ah no
[Applause]
here goes 600 bucks oh you [ __ ] great
top oh my god I hate her but to get some
[ __ ] makeup and cover up your face
that was horrible I'm so sorry
we're talking somebody just cut it off
alright well that was pretty nifty
she says survivor she's gonna give but
she's us a bad but not bad up up pretty
that's cool I like anything me all that
what is that this is scary this is
proper creepy alright
what does that say does that say surface
elevator I don't think an elevator is a
good good idea right now
what is that a minecart is that our way
out that would be so cool Indiana
jones-style just ride it out to victory
I don't trust his planes Brad Saturn
about you but I don't I don't have
strong feelings about this place I feel
like a [ __ ] stuck in this duck
it makes me want to quack like what the
[ __ ] is that okay what's going on here
what is going on here let's check we're
gonna put you in mind card to push it
down solved it before they even became a
problem see that's classic error in game
to sank numbers kidding becoming such an
arrogant [ __ ] no actually that's good
design I think that's cool I'll take it
back okay see you sis cuz it I guess is
versus when you solve a puzzle even
before it you know it's a problem nailed
it
why would you put a door there anyway
such a dumb place what's the purpose of
that door
except for puzzles oddly okay that's
cool I'm blown away by the graphics till
like sometimes you just see parts are
just so pretty
this game really shines on next-gen well
you're asking me
you're asking me okay Emily let's see
here the game is showing something maybe
there was something shining over here
let's check it out
the wind is creepy man I sure oh God in
clue found clocking in machine that was
that a clue
well I'm short on ideas is there
anywhere to get up maybe let's follow
this cable oh here's something I didn't
go here today are we limping yeah here
we go okay what have we got it's all of
this track there's a door
let's go inside come on that door looks
like you're gonna be knocked over pretty
easily fine fine you know what fine okay
that's the clock again just checking it
twice for good luck thank you Lord
o'clock for everything that you do to us
there's something here that we missed
apparently okay what is it
a ladder okay
how convenient oh look she can climb
with an object maybe if MattyB knew how
to do that we wouldn't be [ __ ] dead
right now piss me off
yeah make a clam we did ax even though
there's a killer after us are these are
these jump scare scaring you they're not
like I don't mean to sound like a and
that's scan and this game is that scary
but I don't know it's spooky and I
really enjoy it I think I just played
too many harder games like once you get
comfortable with a horror game it's it's
hard not hard to be scared we'll see
okay something over here
what is it
weird it's a totally weird what is it I
can't really see
I don't what is it I'm sure we'll use it
in a bit
broken ladder okay is this a puzzle this
is the first puzzle in the game we got
this dress nailed it jump to ladder got
it got it
okay keep it good I'm actually rooting
for the girl now I know why she's such
an [ __ ] though why would the game
make the character I clearly stated that
I hated the most living kind of a dick
move
all right and I was like Maddie B is my
my BAE and they're like yeah no [ __ ]
here we're gonna kill MattyB your dick
your dick face I don't care about you
[ __ ] yeah we're gonna [ __ ] you over glad
I made a right there it's so dark
alright I lit up the game play for your
breath but for me it's like proper dark
I it's just that the wider on the
YouTube screen on the YouTube page
okay unless you're watching full page it
makes it so hard to see all right Matt
Matt EP is dead and I am as sorry as you
are about it alright
god damn it I wishes MattyB would come
back it was my BAE who was my boo what
was that huh oh [ __ ]
lucky there's ice flame over there Jesus
[ __ ] her new catchphrases yes our torch
fabulous pick it up girl
pick it up bap bap bap bap and never say
no ever oh this is creepy this is creepy
you gotta play with the sounds to bring
that effect oh yeah this is electricity
that barely barely barely works and now
we can just jump down here and teleport
to victory see this is why you need
teleportation why is no one invented it
yet
now wonder why I like people don't just
don't murder people in their sleep like
that seems like an obvious way to kill
someone
no just me sorry that was that was a bit
weird okay whatever again danger totem
I'm really I thought the totem things
were cool but I like I'm unless they're
happening soon then what's the point
[Music]
okay we got a barrel that's wearing a
blanket and we got a barrel wearing a
blanket and we got things repeating
themself let's just keep going over here
see what we can find
I don't know maybe some panties she
still doesn't have panties right oh god
oh man instead that's kind of sad
oh she actually checks for the carry
what's she doing you think you can get
up there I don't think you can this is
like that one party in Super Mario 64
when you're on the boat and he keeps
sliding down you know what I'm talking
about
I'm being relatable right now relatable
as [ __ ] me how will we make it we need
something maybe that cloth on that
barrel maybe we can steal it it's
already here right well there's
something here and there let's check
them both out
No
whose glasses are these Hanna's Glenn
are they still alive
could that be another twist why would
her glasses be down here
why can I click on this thing nah here
we go
but I mean we clearly saw them dying all
right
I'm just trying to figure it out it's
fun feel free to post your theories in
the comments just watch out for spoilers
why is that here this is really strange
I'm a beast [ __ ] soaking in piss if I
were her what is with the flamethrower
she just walks towards a guy with a
flamethrower why aren't we going up the
slope I guess we could use a
flamethrower
and melt the snow let's check this out
first I want to find all this stuff okay
it's this Venice or Beth's there we go
but I thought she died this is weird
this is very strange
okay let's keep going
there's something here maybe oh that is
creepy I almost missed this I what what
the [ __ ] that's [ __ ] disgusting
so maybe maybe that the guy that tried
to save them
took them down here whoa this is getting
really [ __ ] weird
[Music]
where are we now back to square one but
a BIM better boom badda bang now what
were we doing here exactly guess now
that we have electricity we can use the
elevator
yes that's a great idea
no you can do it should we do this you
boys ready all right all right calm down
calm down
Oh Oh is that oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god oh god oh god I'm trying so
hard not to move don't jump-scare me
don't just get me how the [ __ ] did he
not get back here [ __ ] is he on this is
so intense
come on come on
good idea although he has a
flamethrowers
okay I know why I'm rooting for this
[ __ ] I hate her we tried so hard to
survive I need I need it and okay we're
hiding now
[Music]
please
ah [ __ ] okay we're gonna have to end
that episode there I'm sorry I can't
breasts if you enjoyed this episode as
always leave a like it's so much fun
playing this with you I am loving it and
I hope you are as well I will see you as
promised tomorrow see you then stay
awesome bros